jesus um
i think i'm back
oh let's see i think i just advance here
we're back okay good all right let me i
don't know what happened over on youtube
yeah just it just disconnected that's
not happened to me
frequently before uh but we it looks
like we are back
and are we back on youtube as well
that's the only problem i'm having i
don't know what's happening on youtube
um okay now let me think about this i
think i have to take
i think i'm just gonna try to trade
stuff guys
i think i'm just trying to trade right
now especially with the connection
issues
anybody know if we're back on on youtube
i'm gonna try to fix that uh okay so let
me see
if takes here and takes i don't know
that i need to do that right now
i think
kind of like this idea though see what
happens
youtube's fine okay good oh yeah we're
down to only 58 viewers because of that
little mishap that's too bad but i think
we're okay
now see here then pin
and then i can go for it oh no but then
this okay so that's not good
we're back on youtube okay beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful
i'm kind of liking that i think this is
an idea
yeah the entire youtube stream
completely restarted it's crazy
it's just a crazy situation wow that's
really too bad
oh my god it is my turn okay uh
so now i actually can't do that um i
think i'm taking
and now
i think here
youtube chat is down okay i can fix that
live chat
on 10 okay very good
um so now i do have check
i don't know if it does much for me
but let's just see
um so now i could it's like i mean
there's obviously this but let's go
check uh check this way and if the night
takes i just go check again
okay
here wait a second let me think about
this check it's got to be close to
something good for me right
then here
and then so this doesn't resolve that
problem
let me see here check
and then here
okay that's not really a concern
where do i go here
and then now here
and this has got to be close to made
hold on a second
okay uh here
oh boy where is this going
all right i gotta stop chasing around
here
let me see
pinned
here a lot of chasing around a lot of
chasing around
um now where though
man now i'm actually not sure where to
go i think
i've got to swing back i know i missed
some kind of mate here
um i'll just take that
here here
do i just take the queen and then it's a
pawn game here's another check
uh here's another check and then now i
should be able to get the queen right
wait a second i just messed something up
i think i had the opportunity there for
the queen
yeah i missed the queen that was crazy
that was crazy
uh okay
i definitely missed mate there i
definitely miss mate there
if we could somehow get the king and
queen lined up when they're this far
away
i would be able to get it i got to make
sure i don't run out of time here
um okay let's go oh there it is
there it is beautiful
i think i run a pawn up now quite
frankly there it is all right
wow wow all right let me briefly pause
we have 644 players the most we've ever
had is 732
so we're v we're under 100 players away
from 733 which is where we want to be
so please consider joining the leader
right now
still fm tug i don't know if that's a
known chess player i don't know who that
is
but that would be that would be cool if
it is um
lord overlay is streaming okay that's
interesting
um people talking about my stream
collapsed oh is destiny here is that
true i don't
i have no idea what's going on um i
gotta tell you i'm i'm doing okay right
now
i'm gonna keep going with uh king's
indian
the link is davidpakman.com chess
davidpakman.com
chess it's also in the description on
youtube it's in the description on
twitch so it should be very very easy to
find 40 minutes left in the tournament
still plenty of time
plenty of time i am not going to
fianchetto here
and i'm instead going to play this way
i've been tending to do this as white
with king's indian and it's been going
okay
um and usually i just take
if the pawn comes forward i just take
but it's not happening right now okay
very good
and like i said i usually take in that
situation
and i think i'm actually going to go
this way
would take here there's actually uh
there's actually a lineup of the king
and queen i don't know exactly how i'd
be able to take advantage of it
i think i actually prefer this
in this particular case i wonder how
how could i possibly get this bishop
around
somewhere in here after the king well
now it's done
okay
maybe here just to put a little pressure
on what's going on
obviously can't go here yet
are people fighting in the chat is that
going on i hope everything's okay
um that's not so good now let's see
that's not so good maybe
i get this out of the way
i think maybe this is the way to go
be curious that was move 13 i want to
see if that was actually the best move
there
um okay so
now i think i like the idea of this
then here
actually wait that may not work because
it takes oh no either way it works
actually
let's try it
let's see
so obviously now if i take it's just a
take situation
if i go here
threatening this would have to come here
then check i'm gonna go for it i know
it's a risky play
but i'm just gonna try it there may have
been a miscalculation there
obviously if here then i can't go there
but i can check here which is
interesting
don't know if it does much for me
opponent thinking thinking thinking
right so now the move would be
here is a check
could go here then what
that's the question then what
obviously this would be great let's just
see if they make a mistake
if here i think i just go here
okay i mean all right i guess i'm
trading queens
um and now i'll just have to come up
with something else
maybe start pushing pawns forward it's
not really
clear so clearly this is coming over
so i might go right at the rook
and then keep supporting maybe
so this is undefended it's the only
thing right now
so maybe i defend right here
then i'm almost thinking of this
so wait a second as soon as this moves
then my rook is under attack
so does that really help me
maybe i go this way first then if we get
the bishop on a different diagonal i can
try it
still on the same diagonal
so maybe i just move here
to deal with that issue one at a time
and then here next
let's try it
i mean there's still you know obviously
i would take this trade i think
hmm
so obviously i can go back here then
we'll just move
let's try working over to this side of
the board maybe
i don't know if there's really anything
here but
um
maybe now i start moving some pawns
hmm maybe i need to start getting
the king involved i'm not even sure i'd
like to get my pawns
primarily on dark squares
um
[Music]
yeah this i'm just terrible in this area
i think i just wait here um
i think i like this idea
oh that's not good okay well
can't take here anyway that's something
so i think
try to think if i take moves down no i
have to take that now actually yeah
that's too risky
if here i think i just check let's see
what we can do or do i check this way
actually i like this way better because
eventually i could have this attack
um
here now undefended
this one's getting to be a time scramble
i think this is free right
i
and
here this is getting oh no
wait a second this might be could this
be okay
could have trapped
am i dead in the water
i think is this
am i done oh no now i'm going to lose
the
i'm going to lose the rook
oh man that's not good that's ugly
very very ugly could be dead now
um
not good yep that's it
that's too bad i think there was a move
there
i'm going to look at the analysis board
oh that's weird i thought that was
checkmate
yep there it is let me look at the
analysis board there was a point
where was it okay
here what was the question so
right that was the wrong move right i
could have attacked the queen right here
that would have been the much better
move if i attack the queen queen's got
to go back
has to come here yep okay interesting
interesting all right um if you're just
joining us we have 669 players
i'm trying to get to 733 because 732
was the most i've had during any of
these tournaments
let's go with i'm going to go with a
different opening i'm going to
maybe switch to the ponziani now and see
if anything comes of that
i've been playing that for a little
while
and see if we do and i had pr i'm sure i
missed checkmate in the end yeah it was
it was ugly
let's see what happens here
used to play this a lot go forward
this is like this seems to be someone
who knows what they're doing so this
could actually be pretty tough
usually take this way
now let's see if i check here it's
either
this this this this
or this i don't know that there's much
of an advantage to that
should have brushed up actually on this
opening probably
so now we have a situation i'm gonna go
here i think this is still
sort of okay um i'd rather
here and then here
do i even need to
castle i think i will
i could take the queen
just exchange maybe i do that because
this is a better player
i don't you know i'm just not i'm not
sure whether that was really to my
advantage
um maybe now we start moving pawns
let's see where can we line maybe line
the rook up with the king seems like a
reasonable idea
i'm liking this maybe oh wait a second
wait a second
oh no no no that was uh
i thought i almost had a fork there
let's try here
the link is davidpakman.com chess
davidpakman.comchess that's how you play
uh davidpakman.com chess seems like a
lot of confusion
about the right way to get in uh okay
do i try to trade rooks or do i
think maybe first i just set this up so
that there has to be some defense
there it is um
and then now now what
that's pinned okay so that's this is
maybe an idea
think about this
like it's not obviously bad right now
but usually i end up losing these
positions
where am i going next
right um so no longer pinned
check here
don't want to lose the night maybe this
check
very unclear i'm really just feeling
around in the dark
um now what
maybe here look at something like this
actually i don't even think that works
i mean i guess this is a free pawn but i
might be missing something
oh my god that's what i was missing
right uh okay
that was a mistake that was that was a
blunder that was a huge huge blunder
um okay now now what now i've got to try
to fix that
maybe go after the rook if he comes down
here then i've got a
fork i think i just take it right
check
maybe back off a little
here
this maybe
so if here
what about this maybe
and i think i can take this rook with a
discovered check now
there's that
i think i've got to have this now right
i mean this there's got to be a victory
here somewhere
um don't want to lose the
bishop so i'll just get this
out of the way so if here then here
oh my god no i just got forked
oh my god unbelievable
i guess i have to go here what a
horrible blunder
oh my god what a disaster
classic move for me i mean it was going
too well
all right let's get over here i think i
got to just push the game over in this
direction right
just keeping it interesting just keeping
it interesting exactly
um okay now
what am i doing here maybe i just start
pushing this pawn
got to keep an eye on time what a
tournament what a tournament um so if
here takes i think that's a
fork oh my god what am i doing
what on earth did i just do
holy [ __ ] i just gave away the rook what
am i doing
what on earth am i doing all right i
now it's getting a little too
interesting i would say yeah
i think i'm gonna have to come back here
yep
i think i've got to start taking some of
these right now we're which i'm not even
sure which direction i should be going
in
if i take this
so now what holy geez
this is not good this is not good
if takes i'm not even sure now
all right it's a draw oh my god i've got
to look at this analysis board i was
like just
brutally up right i mean look at this
okay
was what was this then here
and then i would think okay all right i
didn't do that so i failed there
i played there oh my god
and even after this i should have taken
i failed to take what a disaster oh my
god
that was just a mistake in every sense
every sense of the word
691 players 691 players
we are only a few away help me get to
733 we've never had more than 732
players in one of these tournaments
and i would love your assistance getting
to 733 davidpakman.com
chess it's very very easy i encourage
everybody to play
uh we're having a great time we are
going to go with the fianchetto this
time
in the king's indian open i'm going back
to king's indian
knight and then usually here
let's see where we're going next
okay now we've got to start building in
some kind of attack
if here usually i just undevelop here
it's not the end of the world
um where are we going next
i think maybe here just to pin this
that's an interesting idea
yep all right anticipated this
actually there's an interesting move
here
interesting move and i missed it yep i
was hoping for
there could have been this fork here but
that now prevents it
um what where can we go
i think i might try to go after this
night
here maybe yep
um okay
and now
so wait if i take it and then takes it
and then here okay i think i oh actually
no i didn't miss i didn't calculate
does that work
yeah so now right i mean the knight
can't move but i could take it here
maybe this works maybe this works
um
okay wait if i go here then here
then then i just lose okay no that
doesn't work now if here
first
it doesn't work right i don't think it
actually works
i don't think it works
i think i'm just going to take and then
evaluate
so now i can sort of wait
yeah it's not great now even if i
exchange here do i have any attack not
not really
um
all right this is the time is not going
well i think i might try to exchange
here
exchange here then i still have that
defended
do i want to take with this maybe this
is the idea
nope that was idiotic what the hell am i
doing oh my god
guys listen i never pretended to be good
i never pretended to be good okay
please jesus
that was very dumb that was extremely
dumb uh
okay now we've got to figure out
something else here
um i think i'm gonna go right after the
rook let's see what
what can happen is there a checkmate
here that i'm missing
so
let's just take it
now this is available
now i actually am unsure
if i take then i'm opening things up for
the queen i think i'm gonna lock it up
actually
um
here
maybe yeah i don't even really need to
i think i'll just go after the rook
and
maybe go after the rook again
hmm
now that's a problem uh okay
here
this is complex
no running out of time the time is
definitely a problem
very very dangerous i think now here
trade queens maybe yep
and not good here
[Music]
i think i might try to get around
yeah let's see what we can do
can't go here because of this
very tight on time very very tight on
time
back rank's not going to happen now but
still could be an opportunity you can
take here
here if here
um i think i'm taking now i'm protecting
here
need a path here for my
check
and got to get out of the way here
oh that's not good all right now i gotta
get really out of the way
now what am i doing
i'm up but just so limited on time um
i'm to lose the rook now or the night
that's too bad
uh-oh could this happen let me get this
out of the way
trying to remember how this works
there's a particular way i'm supposed to
do this
gotta push into the corner how is it
again
uh here
and here gotta keep
pushing into the corner i believe
right is it here
um oh and i have the bishop too i don't
even know how to use the bishop
oh no i messed it up i messed it up
not good keep the bishop on the diagonal
keep going keep going
oh no i did it again
let's see what we got all right i think
this this actually may be possible
keep going into the corner
and then here uh
gotta avoid making the same move
there we go moving into the corner
moving into the corner very good
keep going into the corner
uh i think i keep going this way right
we might hit the 50 move rule soon yeah
it's going to be a stalemate isn't it
stale i just need to
i just don't remember the technique
there i just don't remember the
technique
um tug is very likely to win this
um with 56 points where am i
160. okay i mean that's not the end of
the world it's not bad
uh thanks to donkey show and willis who
have
subscribed on twitch tyler and the
resident
says are you throwing for content i
don't even know what that means we're
just
we do these chess tournaments every you
know once a month or something like that
all right here we go sticking with
king's indian
i'm actually getting put up against some
better ranked players
um let's go here
pushing forward
continuing to push forward um actually
now i don't want to do that
let's put the queen here for now only 10
minutes left
playing against cluck norris
much better ranked than i am um i think
here i would go and then taken this way
would like to unleash this beast of a
bishop at some point
um but not right now
uh
i don't want to put the queen here
because then i'll be in this line maybe
i just go back
right that was a mistake that was
certainly a mistake
um
i think maybe i take here i have an idea
i mean oh interesting very very
interesting
um the idea i had was
no that doesn't work to attack the queen
while discovering an attack on this
knight
but i don't think that that will work i
mean i guess i could try it this way i'm
guessing that white just defends
how does white defend maybe here
actually i mean because of these two
white could even oh no okay now then i
take the queen
with the pawn that wouldn't work
oh god this isn't good what am i doing
jesus christ i'm an idiot i did it again
guys
yep i did it again um okay i guess i
take here
and then now maybe discover an attack on
the queen this way that was a really bad
move really really but then
then i've got this to deal with so it's
a problem either way
my opponents could be watching me my
opponents could be watching me and i'm
assuming people aren't doing that
because you know
that would be sort of dishonest but it's
certainly conceivable
that they are um all right now
do i attack the queen
if it takes then i would take here
kind of get up i'll go after i'm going
to go after the queen
i mean that this is one of the worst
games so far of the evening i would say
i think i have to move back otherwise
i'm in a problem
um let's see what happens if i go after
that bishop
i'm not really calculating a head i'm
guessing the rook moves to defend it
yep at which point
at which point what maybe
let's see
i'm not bad at giving away rooks i'm i'm
less good at giving away queens at least
lately but i'm less bad at giving away
rooks
um the queen may be tr i mean that my
queen may now be trapped yeah
unfortunately i think what i have to do
is go after their queen
and if here then i have this escape
square yeah
i think that's really the only way i
think that was my only way to save the
queen
now i wonder if
no that that's
hmm
interesting six minutes left in the
tournament likely this would not be my
last game
but maybe the second to last um
now what can i do this is really a
problem now
um
i might i mean do i try to defend
so this is under attack and this is
under attack
that's not good well i could do this so
if i go here and then
here it's a problem either way then
oh then i've got a fork actually i'm
going to try that i'm going to try that
okay that didn't work that didn't work
yeah
this is probably a resign situation
right
this is probably a resign i'll play it
out but
i do have more time
now there could be a problem up top here
oh no that was a mistake that was that
was an idiotic mistake
this is going to get ugly this is going
to get very very ugly
yep there it is wow i actually could
have
um i think there was a moment back here
let me see
so my mistake was pretty early right
it seems it was a series of small
mistakes that wasn't good
and then that wasn't good
now that's interesting why would i do
this
what happens if they take here then i
okay all right that makes sense
and then that oh that was their mistake
interesting i moved to the wrong so my
instinct was right that i had to move
back
and then i think the real turning point
was here right yep there we go that was
a big big big decline so here the right
move would have been
to play here right and then that's where
we would have it
wow wow wow wow well listen i think i'm
not going to go into another game
because it's almost over
otherwise i'd be playing way beyond the
last people let's just see who ends up
winning this thing it looks like it is
going to be
fide master tug are they in a game right
now let's see if we can watch the game
that they're in
uh game is this a current yes this game
is going on all right we're gonna watch
two
clearly a very very good player i don't
know who this is
let's see how this last game goes down
what a tournament really a fantastic
tournament i don't know how many people
ultimately registered
quite a powerful player here
two and a half minutes left in the
tournament
likely the last game
oh is this person in the chat is we will
all die in the chat now i think
is this that the same person
maybe not
going in an interesting direction here
we will all die thinking
and white is resigned let's analyze
who is actually winning here white was
not winning okay yeah so that was
probably the uh that was probably the
right
the right move okay let's go back to the
tournament
we have two minutes to go it doesn't
seem like anybody is going to be able
to catch tug blitz super gm
and irv thalamus interestingly a lot of
the 2000
rated people are not at the very very
top
i'm not going to play any games right
now so people no need to send me any
requests
i do actually i have a bunch of cameos i
need to record after this finishes so
it's not
uh not likely to be any more chess for
me
um sometimes what it comes down to is
that some of the better ranked players
just play fewer games
and playing quickly especially when you
get the double points
uh makes a very very big difference here
in the last 80 seconds here
uh seven to we fell three five players
short of hitting a new record of players
we had 728 people play
and our record previously was 7.32
um well listen
it was a valiant effort this one was
organized we only had like eight days of
promotion
last one i think i promoted it for like
16 or 17 days
or something like that so um as i
mentioned before
i have been invited to play in pog
champs
too i've been invited that's the way i'm
supposed to be saying it
for the time being and um
i'll have more announcements coming soon
but there may be a coaching chess stream
tomorrow night
with someone who may be doing some
coaching of me
so i'll have more information about that
thank you
we had arguably our biggest day ever on
youtube today uh we had a stream with
like 40 000 live
viewers um just a lot of really really
explosive
stuff going on i think we gained two or
three thousand youtube subscribers and
several hundred twitch
followers so it's been a really big
thing truman you said you heard about me
in another stream what does that mean
where did you
i'm curious truman where did you hear
about me
whoa and there are your winners they are
your winners
i'm curious what that means truman like
a uh
oh in the stream of trump did you mean
yes no maybe so we don't know all right
i finished 203rd
can't be altogether no way benjamin
feingold mentioned me i'm that's
fascinating what did what did he say
about me
it's kind of weird to like i'm talking
but you're typing i didn't know benjamin
feingold was aware of me
curious what uh what he said i love his
streams he's a great guy
haven't been really caught up on ben
feingold streams lately though
oh one of his watchers oh oh oh that's
less interesting i'm not
that's a little bit less the fact that a
ben feingold viewer knows about me
that's i mean i love it you know but
it's a little it's marginally less
interesting i will admit
okay that's going to do it for me today
it's been a very long day of streaming
appreciate everybody who played in the
tournament
all 727 of you
we may have more streaming during the
day tomorrow but certainly tomorrow
night
will be the start of my official uh
chess learning um
journey i don't i don't know exactly
what to call it but i'll see everybody
tomorrow thanks
you